- [Voiceover] A system of
equations and their graphs
in the xy-plane are shown above.
How many solutions does the system have?
And I put the picture here on the side.
So we have, we have
three equations here that are presenting
relations between x and y.
And so we have y-squared
is equal to x plus three
so that's...
So we could even show
which ones are which.
This one is this one right over here.
That's this sideways
parabola that we're seeing
right over, actually I'm
having trouble tracing it.
So we have this one right over there.
We have y plus x is equal to negative one,
that's just going to be
this line right over here.
That is a linear equation,
so that's just this line
right over here.
And the last one, the last one,
x-squared plus y-squared is equal to five,
that's equal to that circle.
Now a solution for the system,
this system that has three equations,
two of which are nonlinear.
In order to be a solution to this system,
it needs to be a point that is common
to all three curves, or all three graphs,
or a point that's common to all,
or a point that satisfies
all three of these.
So if we see...
So you might be temped to say, okay,
what about this point right over here?
But this point satisfies the circle
and it satisfies the sideways parabola,
but this point doesn't lie on the line.
In order to satisfy them, you have to...
And this one over here, likewise,
it satisfies the sideways parabola
and the circle, but it
does not satisfy the line.
In order to be a solution for the system,
it has to be an x, y
coordinate that satisfies
all of these three.
And the ones that satisfy all three,
how about this point right over here?
All three lines intersect
at exactly that point
or at least it looks like they do.
And all three points intersect
at exactly that point
right over here.
So this solution has two,
or this system has two solutions.
The four is tricky, because
right when your eyes see this
you see four points of
intersection very naturally.
But it's very important to realize
that this point is only, has
two of the curves intersecting,
not, and this one as well,
only two of the curves intersecting,
not all three.